diese tust du dir das an leider war ich
habe versucht innerhalb von zwölf
stunden fremde leute zu finden die mit
mir von köln bis nach paris über 500
kilometer mit dem fahrrad fahren ob das
geklappt hat und was alles passiert ist
erfahrt ihr im video
ich wurde von fritz meinecke dazu
eingeladen in einem riesigen projekt
kann ihm dabei zu sein wo es darum geht
mit wenigen gegenständen sieben tage
lang in der schwedischen wildnis zu
überleben das problem an der sache ist
sind sechster weil experten dabei will
youtube und ich habe überhaupt keine
ahnung ich bin absolut und trainiert und
genau das wollen wir in den nächsten
wochen ändern weil eben auch nicht mehr
so viel zeit ist bis das projekt losgeht
muss sich schnell handeln und nicht
dafür entscheiden was sie als erstes
machen will
ich wollte an meiner fitness arbeiten
und so schnell es geht mit dem fahrrad
von köln nach paris fahren natürlich
brauchen wir aber auch noch ein bisschen
equipment deswegen habe ich bei rose
angerufen und die haben uns
freundlicherweise ein paar pakete zur
verfügung gestellt
dann kam aber die frage in mir auf gibt
es nicht vielleicht auch noch andere
leute die lust hätten genau das gleiche
zu tun also habe ich eine story gemacht
und gefragt ob es leute aus meiner
community gibt die bereit sind morgen um
12 stunden am kölner dom zu sein und mit
dem fahrrad bis nach paris
ich habe zwei fahrräder da ich hab zwei
komplette ausrüstung werdet euch gerne
hier und dann fahren wir morgen zusammen
in paris titel schöne schwerter jetzt
haben sich eine menge leute gemeldet die
lust und zeit gehabt jetzt mitzufahren
ich habe das fahrrad um das gesamtbild
ab jetzt an eine person gegeben wenn ihr
aber selber einen setup habt wenn ihr
selber ein fahrrad hat umfeld einer
hängematte dann könnt ihr trotzdem mit
rum und wir machen daraus eine community
tour nach paris einen tag planung oder
besser gesagt kein tag planung die räder
sind berlin und ich habe meine mitfahrer
gefunden
rafael hat das zweite fahrrad wir haben
alles fertig gepackt und wir machen uns
jetzt auf dem weg zum dom möglicherweise
irgendjemand steht der mit uns mit 48
ich hätte niemals damit gerechnet dass
so viele leute in so kurzer zeit aus
ganz deutschland anreisen werden und
mehr war aber gleichzeitig auch bewusst
dass es nicht jeder von ihnen schaffen
wird besonders bei einer person war ich
mir ziemlich sicher dass es nicht
schaffen würde ansgar ist aus magdeburg
die komplette nacht angereist mehrmals
umgestiegen wurde aus dem zug
geschmissen weil er nicht das richtige
ticket hatte die steckdose neben ihm hat
angefangen zu brennen und er hat kein
auge zugedrückt aber wo ist das problem
er hatte keinen schlafsack dabei er
hatte kein zelt dabei er hatte keine
luftmatratze dabei sein fahrrad hatte
eine bremse und vor allem wo eingang
also noch schlechter vorbereitet als wir
ging es los auf die große die schnellen
die geben gas langsam letztlich ab das
ist kein rennen
wir werden nicht bis vergisst und auch
nicht gesagt alle gemeinsam in einer
zehner gruppen fahren können
[Musik]
25 kilometer werden
front an sich sieht sehr sehr nahe 170
kilometer sind geschafft wir sind danach
die absolute hölle und der absolute
traum viel besser als gedacht jetzt
probleme heute nochmal 50 hinterher
abzureißen und dann in die auf die 125
zu kommen es regnet ja immer noch
perfekt
ich bin empfiehlt so gut drauf für all
das was wir gerade durchmacht
wo sind in belgien jetzt endlich
ungestört hilft mir auch warum denn
genau der grenze so manchen verletzt als
das auto zum glück habe ich eine
auslandskrankenversicherung über meinen
lieblings versicherungsmanager clark
abgesprochen clark es der perfekte
versicherungsmanager um alle
versicherungen auf einen blick zu haben
der hilft euch dabei die richtigen
versicherung zu finden und wenn nicht
genau wissen in welche richtung brief
versichert sein sollte vielleicht auf
einer speziellen reise wie jetzt bei uns
dann gibt's sogar extra
versicherungsexperten von klagt ihr euch
dabei helfen die perfekte versicherung
für eure bedürfnisse zu finden klagt
euch nicht nur dabei die richtigen
versicherungen zu finden und dabei den
überblick zu behalten sondern klagt auch
komplett kostenlos also klickt den link
in der video beschreibung und ladet euch
clark unter es fängt an zu regnen
wir müssen schnell weiter bei clark
werdet ihr nicht im regen stehen
gelassen ladet euch die app also runter
und teure versicherungen punkt an zu
sparen ist komplett kostenlos
vielen dank dass sie mich in diese
projekte unterstützen unmöglich machen
dass wir und alle leute um mich herum
mit mir nach paris fahren sagen das
interessiert mich nicht
90 kilometer gefahren und ich habe quasi
keine power mehr wissen alle komplett
nass und es machen trotzdem wird
es ist scheißegal absegnet wir sind
allen übels war die stimmung ist gut
unser traum
[Musik]
wir kommen gut voran und wir sind jetzt
vielleicht da in unserem hotel denn wenn
wir uns dagegen entschieden tritt heute
nach draußen zu können denn wir sind
allen übels herrlich denn wissen heute
über 125 kilometer gefahren und so soll
es in den nächsten tagen weitergehen ich
war ja ab geste kann das leckere fühlen
[Musik]
ich habe mich so sehr aufs fahrradfahren
konzentriert das gar nicht im video
richtig rübergekommen ist wie
anstrengend das wirklich wahr
der großteil der gruppe war und
trainiert und er habe am ersten tag 100
und 30 kilometer gefahren für die beine
für den hintern und so ziemlich jedes
andere körperteile ist ist eine absolute
tortur wenn es dann noch regnet und man
in den nächsten tagen mit dem
verregneten klamotten wieder starten
muss ist das nicht die allerbeste
ausgangssituation für den ersten tag
deswegen sind wir die erste nacht ins
hotel gegangen und zumindest ein
bisschen schlau
anders sah es bei unserem freund anker
aus der um 37 bei uns an der tür im
hotel geklopft hat weil er zu dem
zeitpunkt dann im hotel angekommen war
37 morgens komplett durchnässt hat er
dann während wir gefrühstückt haben eine
stunde zeit gehabt seine sachen
ansatzweise zu trocknen was natürlich
nicht funktioniert hat und dann war aber
klar wir müssen weiter alle wollten so
schnell wie es geht nach paris und es
war klar dass es nicht jeder schaffen
würde und dass wir hier und da leute
verlieren ansgar war aber trotz wenig
schlaf trotz zwei nächte wenig schlaf
direkt die damit am start und ist mit
uns los gerade auch wenn wir ihnen nach
fünf kilometern dann direkt von
vornherein war klar alle müssen in ihrem
eigenen tempo fahren müssen entweder so
schnell fahren dass sie mit der
schnellsten gruppe mit kommen oder
langsamer in eigenem tempo
hat zufällig noch jemand eine kette
dabei nummer 2008 jetzt kann endlich
weitergehen und wir haben große heute
vor mindestens so viele kilometer wie
gestern und möglicherweise noch mal ein
bisschen mehr bitte let's go
[Musik]
230 km 5 unsere gruppe doch eindeutig
keine hunde sind jetzt nur noch mit
sechs leuten unterwegs die aber alle
genau das gleiche tempo fahren und sich
gegenseitig mit sind aber auch dass wir
dich in einer gruppe sein
haben sie etwa 70 kilometer geschafft
wie hätte es anders sein sollen
natürlich wenigstens aber erst nach 300
km der erste platte reifen bis dato lief
eigentlich alles ganz gute start ob ich
mal ein bier wir haben die guten dinge
daten erfasst sind niemals das ja bei
uns nach wie vor alles tipptopp alles
spreche alle scheine vielen vielen dank
an rose noch mal dass wir uns die beiden
räder zur verfügung gestellt haben
dieses und dieses ein absoluter traum
ist es ein gedicht und unser reifen es
eben auch nicht wirklich 250 kilometern
alle verrückt geworden
schlecht gestärkt aber dafür gut
ausgeruht jetzt weiter ich komme so
langsam an meine grenzen
[Musik]
es gibt dem zweiten kind
mit
letzte paar meter hey du hast du da wir
im schlaf platz für die zweite nacht
gefunden also der schlafplatz ist ein
traum aber meine verfassung ist die
absolute hölle ich merke dass meine
beine komplett am start sind und jetzt
richtig anfangen zu arbeiten und das zu
verarbeiten was in den letzten tagen
passiert ist sehr entspannt und ich bin
eine sekunde nach dem hier ins bett
gefallen bin absolut werde jetzt
komplett durchzuschlafen bis morgen und
in irgendeiner weise zu verarbeiten über
nacht was in den letzten tagen passiert
ist
am ende von tag 2 hatten wir unser
gesamtes equipment aufgebaut also zählt
luftmatratze schlafsack und so weiter
und von ansgar bewahren nach wie vor
keine spur
also habe ich ihm eine sprachnachricht
gemacht in der ich ihnen erkläre warum
ich es für schlauer halte warum es der
sicherere weg ist wenn er den
schnellsten weg nach hause antritt und
ich sage dir ganz ehrlich wir sind so
weit voraus musst du schauen ob sich das
für dich lohnt um es kurz zu fassen
manche leute konnten nicht mit dem tempo
mithalten andere leute hatten nicht das
richtige equipment bei ansgar beides der
fall aber er hat einfach nicht
aufgegeben alles gut wie möglich ist die
ganze zeit weiter gefahren jeden tag
fünf oder sechs stunden länger als wir
die schnellere gruppe und hat einfach
über die zeit dann die kilometer wieder
rausgeholt kam aber trotzdem nicht ganz
anderes ran
so sah das ja aus wir haben direkt neben
so einer fabrikhalle gepennt dadurch
hatten wir schutz von der seite hier auf
der anderen seite ging es ein bisschen
hoch und jetzt frühstück geht eine
banane tag 3 es geht los wir sind
komplett am ende aber an bord kann das
ziel ist in sicht wären mehr als die
hälfte der strecke geschafft und den
rest liegen jetzt auch noch in let's go
25 km in der tour drin wir fahren durch
feinste natur die ganze zeit zwischen
irgendwelchen kornfeldern her frankreich
es einfach viel zu riesig die 760
millionen einwohner die sie haben um für
den dritten tag alle erstaunlich fit
[Musik]
und placebo spaghetti kurve logos und
kilometer von alaska und presse mercedes
wie die soli europa das größte problem
an unseren etappen ist dass wir immer
zeitlich so bei unserem mittags stopp
ankommen das schon 14 oder 15 uhr sind
in frankreich ist völlig normal ist dass
die restaurants um 14 uhr einmal die
küche zu machen und das passt uns
überhaupt nicht genau so verschiebt sich
dann unser zweiter stopp abend wieder
auf 21 oder 22 uhr die kirchen dann
schon wieder schließen und wir bekommen
meistens nie was vernünftiges zu essen
und wir brauchen ein vernünftiges niveau
der partie
das dachten wir zumindest was uns nicht
bewusst war raffael hatte in seinem
freestyle französisch für sechs leute ht
bestellt was zeigt bedeutet und nicht
für sechs leute packt bestellt was
nudeln gewesen wäre war so dumm
es war so dumm noch ein bisschen
diskussionen hat es dann aber trotzdem
funktioniert und nach drei tagen ohne
warme mahlzeit hatten wir endlich alle
einen teller nudeln front stehen der uns
dabei geholfen hat danach endlich wieder
mit power weiterfahren zu können und das
kannst du niemandem erzählen und dann
kürzlich kurz nach der pause fährt eine
person auf dem parkplatz hätte niemand
mehr gerechnet hat krank oder ja das ist
der absolute post ich komme da nicht
auch klar wieso tust du dir das an
leider er will
ich komme da nicht darauf klar ich komme
bestimmt sechs schon oben hin ist hier
immer 30 km weil wir immer weiter
gefallen
das ist komplett geschäft und seine
kette hält gut gestärkt geht es weiter
auf die 56 kilometer heute und damit
auch die letzten 150 richtung paris
zwischen stamm- pack 3 ja gerade von der
autobahn runter ins dorf geschossen
alter das so aufregend
[Gelächter]
90 km gleich im dorfe zelt aufschlagen
supermarkt umso höher hätte ich mir
vorher jemand gesagt dass ich 100
kilometer als sehr entspannt wahrnehme
hätte ich ihn wahrscheinlich nicht
abgenommen und 100 kilometer haben sich
als absolut nichts heraus gestellt und
alles was danach kommt wird deutlich
deutlich schwieriger quasi exponentiell
spielen
[Musik]
die letzten meter für heute dritter
abend wir sind wieder draußen die zelte
stehen wir legen uns hin und machen uns
ready für die allerletzte etappe morgen
gehen paris 6 uhr 10 tag nummer vier ist
rafa hier bin ich das einen dreckigen
zelt zwei personen zum luftmatratze
dabei kraft hatte ich auch eine gekauft
hat er war auf dem weg von dort unsere
beiden schlafsäcke bis 0 grad geeignet
sehr wichtig vor allem heute nacht und
das wird mir jetzt wieder
zusammenbasteln und dann waren wir die
letzten 100 kilometer nach paris
richtigkeit potenzielle ankunftszeit 16
17 uhr
der finale ja um eine auch alter
ja denn jemand schmerz die letzten 40
kilometer nach paris am angebrochen
dyballa märz noch durch und ich schätze
in den nächsten zehn kilometern könnte
jetzt anfangen das auf die stadt schauen
können
da war sie mitten in paris aber die
strecke ist jetzt noch mal richtig geil
geworden wir waren quasi mitten durch
den wald ist ein absoluter traum niemand
es hier und wir haben jetzt ganz
entspannt endlich zu 20 kilometer
[Musik]
und nach 500 kilometern einem hinterteil
auf dem man nicht mehr sitzen konnte
brennenden bein einem viel zu dicken
knieblessuren an allen möglichen stellen
hatten wir es tatsächlich geschafft
[Musik]
dazu waren wir aber so fertig dass
selbst bei der ankunft am eiffelturm
nach noch zwei stunden durch den pariser
stadtverkehr fahren keiner mehr kraft
hatte sich richtig darüber zu freuen
dass wir da waren zumindest nicht
offensichtlich darüber zu freuen wir
waren alle mega fertig alle super happy
dass es geklappt hat es war eine
unglaubliche reise
es war ein unglaubliches erlebnis und
ich habe wirklich das gefühl besser
vorbereitet zu sein auf sein erstes
white einfach weil es eine absolute
kopfsache war in vier tagen nach paris
wir sind eine
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit von 22 km h
bis nach paris gefahren über 500
kilometer über 3000 höhenmeter und das
soll es gewesen sein dass meine lieben
freunde war die geschichte wie ich mit
sechs leuten aus meiner community 500
kilometer nach paris zum eiffelturm
vielen dank dass ihr das video bisher
angeschaut habt lasst ihr video gerne
leichter vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren damit wir uns nächste woche
wiedersehen und schaue mir gerne in
kommentare was ich noch machen soll
wo mich vernünftig auf das projekt
betritt vorzuhalten macht's gut
[Musik]